last week was an extremely difficult
week for my family as a whole the
podcast is going to be airing today that
you're watching was filmed prior
to My Life falling apart so Savannah
Chrisley admits her new reality is
looking dark exactly one week after
parents Todd and Julie surrendered to
prison look any family who faces a loved
one going to prison it's a very
difficult Challenge and for the latest
challenge well for Savannah it's
carrying on with her unlocked podcast we
kind of had to say goodbye to my parents
for
somewhat you know for a little bit of
time for the foreseeable future what we
will not do is we will not break
Savannah tells fans this week's podcast
was recorded nearly two weeks ago days
before her mom and dad began serving a
combined 19-year prison sentence last
week was an extremely difficult week for
my family as a whole and for each of us
individually and I haven't filmed the
podcast since then and she uses the
intro to get candid about her dire
Outlook the podcast is going to be
airing today that you're watching
um was filmed prior to My Life falling
apart so if Todd and Julie could share a
message with the world what do you think
they'd want them to know that they are
the same people they've always been that
they didn't do these things and they're
going to fight to get their name cleared
because God didn't bring us this far to
drop us off last year Todd and Julie
were convicted of bank fraud and tax
evasion as far as what you can do for us
you can pray that's more than we can
ever expect from anyone I've never seen
two people my parents be so steadfast in
their faith in the end the truth will
prevail may get harder before it gets
easier but we have faith and that faith
is crucial as the Chrisleys plead their
innocence from behind bars the reality
stars have until February 22nd to file
their appeal the reality of it for me is
that when you know you did not do these
things
and you and you have and and yet you sit
you stand here convicted you that's
that's a hard pill to swallow I think
they're optimistic but let me be clear I
think that optimism is well placed this
trial was riddled with heirs and we
expect the appeals court to see that
next week I will have a very
intense
one-on-one podcast with myself and give
an update on my parents um because you
guys don't have one yet and
I'm really
I'm really looking forward to giving
that update because I've seen God work
and
the craziest of circumstances in a
federal prisons each one has a different
visitation schedule you are allowed to
visit with family and again this is a
close family and they're obviously going
to spend time visiting with one another